prime minister mustafa akademi arrived
in basra
only hours after returning from his trip
to washington dc
he met local politicians late on
saturday night with the hopes of calming
the anger on the streets
but he had a warning for those looking
to cause
this is a message to all criminals and
killers this is a new government that is
working to establish the prerequisites
of security
it aims to establish security and
prevent crime
i'd like to tell everyone who carries a
weapon contrary to the government's law
they wouldn't escape punishment and the
killers will be brought to justice very
soon
i'd like to tell the criminals who
assassinated hisham hashemi
the young female doctor that your blood
will be a title for justice
thirty-three-year-old rehab nakoop is
the young female doctor prime minister
kaldemi referred to
she was a prominent activist in basra
and led several women's marches
she was killed on wednesday when gunmen
with assault rifles riding a motorcycle
opened fire on her car days earlier
gudman had shot dead activist tassine
osama
their deaths sparked days of protests
and unrest
fueled by anger protesters set fire to
local government buildings in the
southern iraqi city
demanding those responsible be brought
to justice and calling for the
resignation of the provincial governor
assad al-idani the recent rise in
targeted killings
poses a challenge for the new prime
minister there have been nearly a dozen
attempts on the lives of well-known
activists this month
and four have been killed three of them
in basra
the prime minister dismissed the local
police chief last week
after osama's death in response a number
of senior tribal leaders issued a
statement saying they'll arm themselves
if the government fails to protect the
people this is the worst unrest the city
has seen since last year's
protest which led to the resignation of
prime minister adal abdul mahdi
basra is known as the wealthiest
province in iraq
it's home to most of the country's oil
reserves yet
it has some of the worst facilities in
public services
years of mismanagement and corruption
have led to protests on a regular basis
let's go live to dorset jabari who's in
baghdad dorset do we have any further
updates about what the situation is like
in basra
yes rob we've just been hearing from a
number of protesters who've
reached out saying that they have begun
to gather
in the city of basra and that they feel
that their demands have not been met so
we're expecting to
see some crowds again this evening in
that city we also
have heard from the newly appointed
chief of police in basra province
he issued a directive earlier on sunday
to his entire staff and all the security
apparatuses
in that province there was a number of
things he highlighted the first was that
there are to be no
armed civilians in that province this is
something that the police will be trying
to regulate
encouraging people to lay down their
arms to try and
dissuade people from escalating the
tensions that are ongoing the other
issue that was mentioned in this
directive by the newly appointed police
chief is that
vehicles that do not have license plates
will be stopped and taken in
by police said this is in an attempt to
try and rein in
these militias that many believe are
behind these
killings of these protesters things
appear to be
very tense in that province the prime
minister academy has
left basra already we understand that
he's back in the capital
and the protesters that we've been
hearing from over the past
a few minutes say that they have
gathered yet again and they are going to
demand the same thing that they've been
demanding over the past few weeks
the local governor needs to resign and
there needs to be accountability
there needs to be people brought to
justice for these killings
as dorset jabari bringing us up to date
from baghdad on the situation
in the southern city of basra dorsa
thank you very much